hey mom I obviously know it to you you
don't have to introduce yourself every
time fine everything's good
well my girlfriend dumped me and I'm
hungover but I'd rather not talk about
that with you
so what's been going on with you how are
things so I'm gonna act like I'm
interested in what you're doing even
though I couldn't care less
oh yeah doing what can you keep talking
for a few seconds so I don't have to
answer any more questions right I'm a
freaking mcclain makes you so hot hey
mom you know what I got a run hey mom
I have nor else to be but I really want
to get off the phone right now wait I
need to talk to you about something
sure what's up oh [ __ ] did you finally
find out about that thing have you
talked to your sister
few days ago why by talking me texted
then yes no mom asked first she told me
not to tell you you know that I'm fine
we're not talking about this again right
yeah and there it is the actual reason
why you called I'll agree with anything
you say just to change the topic mom
just so you know I'm checking out of the
conversation right now you need time
okay
why are we still doing this when you
know I'm not listening I know Mom okay
I'm tuning back in you're about to say
something sentimental I love you I love
you too I love you too okay